you know I spent a lot of time sitting
and talking with players and team owners
prior to even announce it illegal we
were designing it and I mean the this
there's so many stories if you look at
the history of eSports of just bad
things happening to players so one of
the things was like let's let's make
this a league where every gamer in the
world aspires to be a part of it when
you make it to overwatch League it's
amazing you're a professional athlete
you're treated like that you have all
this infrastructure and you your you're
a you're a superstar with all the talk
of grand visions and investment millions
it's easy to forget that ultimately the
future of the league rests on the
shoulders of a few young passionate
overwatch players they've come from far
and wide
some with experience in eSports others
with just the dream of being able to
play their favorite game for a living
each one of them has challenges to
overcome be it in unfamiliar culture a
language barrier or the need to prove
the legitimacy of their chosen career
they are all taking a risk hoping that
they can establish themselves as the
best overwatch players in the world and
perhaps pioneer a new future for eSports
too in many ways the overwatch League is
only as strong as those competing within
it and in this episode we sat down with
the young ambitious athletes who are
chasing their dreams for success in an
emerging eSport
[Music]
I was living in my friend's house for
like a month
and I just found out all over watch it
was just released
I really thought overwatch was gonna be
really big eSports and I just decided
you know I think I'm just gonna be a pro
if from the get-go I want to be a pro I
know I know what I need to do I know the
mistakes I made I think I can do this I
had a plan I had a plan I swear you know
like the budget was there I was like all
the money I made from streaming and nice
tourism winnings from league and I was
like I'm gonna I'm gonna take everything
I made from here to the Mets at
overwatch and I got my own place in
Koreatown in LA and I lived there for
about a little bit more than a year and
I I tried competed in the like tier 3
and eventually it's here to seen and I
had like less than three dinners in my
bank account and I don't even know what
to think I just I can I pay my rent I
just like what do I do after scrim I
just got a call from like a lot of yours
they're like hey ya wanna play and I was
like I was pretty cool about it but yeah
yeah that sounds great
and I was inside I was like jumping
around getting the journey to get to the
professional level is it's a really hard
thing it's really hard to see the
journey going forward likes to connect
that dot going forward I knew when the
game first released into beta I really
wanted to at least give it an
opportunity to go pro so that's one of
the main reasons I moved to North
America it's just one of those things
you just really got to put everything
you have into it if you if you try and
sort of like half-ass it or you know not
really give it everything you have it's
really hard to sort of reach that top
level so it's something you got to be
really prepared for you know the journey
I mean I've always been a huge nerd in
my entire life I remember when Starcraft
2 started to blossom as a big eSport I
tried to show my mom look they get paid
to play this game I want to do that you
know and she couldn't understand it or
my dad can understand it the only one
who really understood like eSports and
what this was my brother
my big brother it's still like kind of a
conundrum to my parents I guess
I mean my family never against me for
playing game as a profession or
something but in Highland we have the
problem that the children they addict
to the game and they do nothing they're
better studying I like everything is
going bad it was sort of a hard sell at
the at first I said I wanted to go play
video games professionally and I wasn't
gonna get paid for a while until I
unless I actually made if I didn't make
it I wasn't gonna get paid ever but I
believed in myself my family trusted me
to do what I thought was best for me
skepticism towards a career in eSports
is unsurprising for many people video
games are still considered a hobby not
to be taken seriously the idea of
dedicating your entire life to them is
filled with questions and the prospect
of trying to earn a living from them
with uncertainty
if overwatch League was to have any sort
of legitimacy Blizzard had to tackle
these concerns for it to grow it needs
to attract players and to attract
players it needs to show there are
valuable opportunities and stability we
had all heard these horror stories of
exploitation that was happening to pro
players in eSports where you know teams
weren't paying their players or they
didn't win a land and they wouldn't
share the prize pool or all these sort
of disasters that were going on and one
of the things that Nate was very vocal
about was protecting the players and
making sure that they were salaried that
they had benefits that the team's really
had an obligation to their players and
that we were gonna put that into the
contracts and make sure that these young
and upcoming superstars were not
exploited or taken advantage of that
they not only had a lot of rights but
that they were compensated extremely
well whether their team was winning or
losing and that there was lots of room
for growth and there was more to this
than hey show up to the land and maybe
you'll win some money maybe you won't
that's not that's not professional in
our opinion
the thing about eSports before this was
like you can be playing tournaments with
a team before that and then the next the
next day you can be cut and then all of
a sudden you don't have a source of
income anymore I watch leagues sort of
gave us that guaranteed benefits and
salary for at least a year so it really
allows you to forget about money forget
about all the exterior circumstances of
life and just focus on the game which is
really important you know when you're at
the professional level I wouldn't say I
feel safer because at the end of the day
it's a talent industry and you have to
perform to be able to keep your job
it is of course very very nice that they
have like this baseline salary which is
as you would say it legitimizes eSports
in a way I feel like it's more
professional everything is kinda like
bigger and we have like as you can see
the sponsors it's not just like the
gaming gear or like everything that's
related to the computer or like internet
something like that it's way bigger than
that and I think it's kind of like get
to the point that can call it as a real
sport now a lot of different games are
jumping on the same trend like League is
trying to franchise it eliminates the
unprofessional scene in eSports and with
Blizzard coming in and saying no we're
gonna do this way it really lifts up
eSports in a good light and this is
actually a real thing this is actually a
league which is really awesome to see
what's really important to us that the
players could have a real career at this
it's encouraging to me to see and our
first season how many teams they don't
just have like a coach to have a data
analyst and they have a performance
coach and they have a physical trainer
and a nutritionist and they're working
on their sleep schedules and to see that
level of rigor around what they're
building to see the level investment is
really encouraging I think it's really
important for the players to know that
at the highest level in the company
they're supported so that they know that
if they need something to help them
perform better but they don't have to go
through ten different layers of
management to get it they can tap on the
guy who actually hired them to to
provide those things for him playing
eSports is it's a tough job there's a
lot of pressure
not only just like from your teammates
in your family but tons of fans and
having a really strong base of people
behind you within the company can help
you get through like the hard times for
overwatch league players the demands go
beyond just performing in game with more
eyes on them than ever before
each one is thrust into the spotlight
where their words and actions all
contribute to building their profile and
strengthening their brand part of being
an overwatch league player means also
being a personality for people to latch
on to you know I think it's a big
challenge for young people like if you
think about the average age of a player
League is probably you know 20 21
something in that zone a lot of these
players League especially even younger
ones than that there's some people that
are literally moving like from home -
now I'm a internet famous eSport player
I went from like nobody knows who I am
to now I have ten thousand Twitter
followers and now you sort of get under
this microscope and we have a
responsibility our team owners have a
responsibility to help prepare our
players for that and give them the tools
they need to be successful but I think
we're always going to encourage our
players to have personality but we're
also gonna encourage our players to be
respectful and professional and act like
professionals I mean they are
representatives of the game fans look up
to them and especially a game like
overwatch which has a pretty young
audience nobody wants to be told that
hey guess what you're a role model now
but the reality is like there's a lot of
young kids that really look up to the
players I never know what to say when
like oh yeah I like I'm looking up to
you or not even that boy I just want to
be a pro gamer or my son's trying to be
a pro gamer that's the hardest one when
mom's asking you oh yeah my son he's
like pretty good but he really wants to
be a pro gamer and I don't not sure if
I'm not sure if I just stop you know I
just like I just like stop and thing
cause like what do I need to say hear it
cuz I'm sure I want to say like go for
it but then the amount of like emotional
stress and like it's a marathon it's
like it's like there's like so many
things that you need to constantly do
and it's so easy to get burnt out even
the professional players it's like
compared to watching stage one like
right now we're in Stage four and
they're like
the player that really didn't know how
to balance life I guess it's the
weirdest thing you've ever you've ever
experienced especially coming from
really nothing like I'm just here to
play video games I'm just here to I'm
just here to compete and then you had
these people looking up it's it's a
really humbling thing knowing that you
can have an impact on other people's
lives and like have these people to spy
to you at that point is just about being
the best role model you can be obviously
there's a lot of things that I've had to
change you know I'm not perfect the most
important thing is being yourself in the
public because people don't want to
aspire to someone that who's not
actually her there
give it up from the Florida mayhem my
nephew who is 13 now he always watched
me when they already came over to I
would sit there in pavilions he would
always take a shower and watch what I'm
doing at the beginning he started
playing Hansel when I tried to no no no
play something different but he really
loved the game as well and then when I
started traveling places and playing
tournaments he would tell his friends
about it at home and it would all sit
and watch the games my big sister was
the mother of my nephew of course she
messaged me and she was like oh whenever
when you come home you have to meet all
his friends because they're just talking
about you all the time and they really
want to meet you you know and it was
crazy to think about how much passion
they have for the game when it comes to
eSports since there are a lot of people
who aren't familiar with pro sports
there's the assumption that everything
should be perfect and there should be no
missteps along the way and the reality
is both with eSports and pro sports
we're talking about very young very
talented individuals who might not be at
a stage of life where everything is
gonna go perfect for them as we know
even at an older stage of life nothing
goes perfect for us so I don't know why
we would think at 18 or 19 we would be
these perfect model citizens at all
times people are people and just because
you're talented whether it be at a sport
or at a video game doesn't mean you're
not going to be without your flaws I
think we have to just be Oh
been to an accepting that there's gonna
be some rough edges but that's sort of
what makes it cool and interesting and
not always look at those rough edges as
failures undef initely miss him a lot I
want to go back and meet my friends I
mean I miss my family but I'm not young
I'm adult so I need to learn how to
leave alone I need to learn how to
handle the situation it's kind of like
it's a real world it's a how do you say
that reality it's okay now but when I
was in high school things were rough cuz
like for me at least I was like never I
was okay at studying you know for amount
of time I spent in studying the grades
were like aren't weren't that good so I
was like never really that into study
sports world cabe I never let it get to
like play team sports so I think like I
always felt like I've missed out on
those you know as cheesy as it sounds
like I was like I never had like a
teammate on any of these ports and I
always like want to work with people I
want to like play games other people and
put things off that other people can't
when I finally was introduced to
something that I enjoyed that I was good
at those those two are like something
that never happened together it was like
I had heard like something and I was
completely garbage at it where I'm good
but I just hate it or I'm like decent
when I'm hating it and I know like I
would like never get good because I
would never spend the extra effort I
missed out on a lot of opportunities
before when I was like I was always like
too shy or I didn't really have the
commitment or the drive to really like
go out of my way to build my own brand
after I got into overwatch League just
my my mindset changed a lot I guess I
guess maybe it was just because I was
like never just script before and it
just felt like I was given one last
chance to really really come back and
really make the most out of my love for
gaming my parents would probably be like
the best
okkk to look at in terms of skepticism
to you know approval because you know
when I first went to my mom and I was
like hey I want to drop out of
university and I want to go play video
games in North America it was it wasn't
easy for her but you know she's my
number one fan she she's slowly learn
about the industry and understanding hey
this is actually something that's big
this is something that's growing these
people are actually like a big deal and
that they are trying to get to the level
that sports is that so it is a hard sell
for people especially the older generate
since you don't really understand it as
much but I think within the new
generations it's becoming a lot more
common I think to have a goal of
becoming an overwatch league
professional player is amazing but
really challenging at the same time when
you consider how few pros exists in the
world
you know how limited the rosters are and
the fact that there's currently 12 teams
that's gonna be a big challenge to make
it on that team I don't think that
should dissuade people from trying to
achieve that goal I think one of the
things that happens to all of us in our
life is as we chase certain goals we
realize the path that our life should
actually be on and the goals that we
should actually be chasing so I think
people will calibrate I thought I was
going to be an amazing novelist someday
and that was going to be my career of a
brilliant writer and I'm probably one of
the worst writers that I've ever read so
we all have to be willing to adjust in
our paths every once in a while
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
metallus unbelievable before
looks like old
[Music]
in the final episode of this series we
reflect on blizzards vision for
overwatch league its achievements so far
and where everyone involved hopes it
will go in the future
[Music]
you
[Music]